senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
senator thanks for being here
glad to be with you the negotiations
over coronavirus bill
possible well i hope so i've been trying
to get an
outcome here for quite a while as you
may recall a few weeks ago i put a
rescue package on the floor of the
senate targeting kids
jobs health care and liability
protection
and at that point we couldn't get a
single democrat to vote for it so i
think what's happened here is we've
gotten closer to the election
the spirit of bipartisanship on
coronavirus that we had in march and
april has largely
disappeared what is your number the
house democrats are saying they've come
down what is your number what can you
stomach
well what i put on the senate floor
three weeks ago
was about a half a trillion dollars
narrowly targeted
at exactly what the economy needs at
this point
what the speaker did even after coming
down a full trillion dollars
is throw everything you can imagine into
the package including tax cuts for
rich people in california new york and
free health care for illegal immigrants
that sort of thing is not appropriate
so you sound pretty pessimistic look i'd
like to get another
rescue package i think there's more that
needs to be done for the economy
but it's important to remember we
already now have a depth the size of our
economy for the first time since
world war ii this has got to stop unless
it's narrowly
targeted at the problem all right but
one more try
if they come down to 1.2 are you can you
get there
brad i'm not going to negotiate with you
the principal negotiations between the
president and the speaker of the house
if they can reach an agreement i'll take
a look at it and see whether i can sell
that
to senate republicans all right speaking
of selling it have you definitively
decided
that if amy coney barrett gets out of
the senate judiciary committee let's say
october 22nd as planned
that you will have a vote before
election day
yeah i haven't decided when the vote
would occur on the floor but we do
anticipate
judge barrett coming out of committee on
october 22nd
i think that's a pretty likely outcome
and then we'll decide
when to go forward well how much debate
time should there be
for a lifetime appointment well there's
plenty of
debate going on in committee it started
today even without the
nominee there the american people i
think really need an opportunity to get
to
meet and know judge barrett and that'll
happen during the judiciary committee
hearings we were calling each other
hypocrites before what we need to see is
the nominee
and we'll have an opportunity to do that
over the next few weeks she's
spectacular
an incredible life story wonderful
family five kids two adopted kids one
special needs kid
and one of our professors at notre dame
wrote an op-ed in the washington post
recently saying she was the single most
brilliant
student he'd ever had in all of his
years teaching law
at notre dame for the election lookers
who say
how does this supreme court nominee amy
coney barrett play
for these tight republican races how how
do you see it
as far as if you get this nominee
through
how does it play in those races well the
the pending nomination i think is a big
asset i'm happy
to put this nominee front and center
in my campaign i'm happy to tell the
voters of kentucky
my opponent would oppose this
outstanding nominee
supporter i think it's an asset in my
state and an
asset in many many states around the
country
let's say you don't get it before
election day last question on this
and election happens let's say on your
from your perspective optimistically you
hold on to the senate majority
but there will be some senators in your
caucus who lose
is it okay for a lame duck senate to
vote on a supreme court
nominee to be a justice well this
republican senate was elected for
a term that ends in january of next year
the president was elected for a
four-year term that ends january
20th of next year there are no
reduced constitutional prerogatives
during either of our 10 years and in
fact brett you will remember two years
ago when
my party actually gained two seats in
the senate while we were losing the
house
the biggest issue in the campaign was a
supreme court nominee
brett kavanaugh how do you describe the
debate
that happened the other night well it
wasn't lincoln douglas i can tell you
that
does it hurt your uh senate
folks who are up for election this time
well there'll be two more debates and i
hope both the candidates
will approach the next debate in a
little more respectful way it'd be good
idea i think to let
each of the candidates finish their
answers
but look they're the candidates they get
to decide how to engage with each other
and uh we've got two more to go and
i'm hoping they'll be a little uh better
for the american people's viewing
yeah here's how the hill wrote it they
said instead of spending wednesday
touting nominee amy coney barrett
senators republican senators spent the
day fielding questions about the
president's refusal to directly rebuke
white
white supremacist groups or to commit to
a peaceful transfer of power
senator tillis who's trailing his
democratic opponent in recent polls
declared white supremacy or any
organizations
that are antagonistic should be
condemned 24 7.
senator daines who's in a tough
reelection race quipped
it was a bar room brawl and as we say in
montana it got a little western at times
so it just takes some days away from the
campaigns
well with regard to white supremacy
there's no place for that in america
i and others all of my colleagues
condemn it in the strongest possible
terms
i think senator tim scott from south
carolina probably said it better than
anyone we all would be better off
immediately condemning white supremacy
wherever
we hear references to it if the election
does not get decided on november 3rd and
there are some states that are still
having problems getting to
finding their final number or their
electors how do you think that would
look
from a congressional perspective well it
could happen
i mean there's no question that how
elections are conducted
or decided in each of our states and
some states have
adopted an approach to this with regard
to
the counting of mail-in ballots that
could delay the results
it could happen
would have to wait to find out who won
but there's nothing the federal
government can do about that if a given
state decides
to conduct an election in a certain way
that's the way it'll be conducted
in my state for example we used to
mostly vote in person
this time there'll be more mail-in
voting because of the coronavirus
i accept that as the outcome in my state
of how the election is going to
be conducted and i'll adjust my campaign
accordingly
who knows i mean we we think this will
be settled well before the end of the
year
no matter you know how many
states may end up having short-term
election disputes we saw it in 2000 go
on for five weeks
but it was settled well in advance of
the time for the new president and a new
congress to be sworn in
senator mitch mcconnell we appreciate
your time thank you